Вітаю! Мене звати Чемерис Світлана і
ми з вами продовжуємо вивчення географії.
Сьогодні ми з вами продовжуємо
знайомитися з водами суходолу
і темою нашого уроку будуть
льодовики та багаторічна мерзлота.
Ми з вами звикли бачити
лід на річках, озерах
та ставках взимку, коли вони замерзають.
Ми звикли, що це щось статичне, нерухоме.
Крига вкрила річку і поки не розтане,
поки не потеплішає, вона там знаходиться.
Але сьогодні ми знайомимося з
вами з трошки іншими льодовиками.
Льодовики — це багаторічні
рухомі природні скупчення льоду.
І на відміну від тієї криги, яка
вкриває наше озеро або ставок,
ці льодовики утворені
не з води, а з снігу,
тобто накопичується сніг,
який не тане протягом року.
Льодовики розподіляються по
території планети дуже неровномірно.
От ми бачимо, що льодовиками
вкрито всього 11% площі суходолу.
Так було не завжди.
Колись льодовики
вкривали більшу територію,
до 30% в періоди давнього зледеніння.
Потім льодовики танули.
І на сьогоднішній день ми
бачимо, що їх залишилося 11%.
Як же вони розподілені
по території планети?
Із цих льодовиків, які залишилися
у нас 85% припадає на Антарктиду,
11% на Гренландію, і трошки
більше 3% це весь інший суходіл.
Чи на всіх материках є
льодовики? Ні, не на всіх.
Австралія не має льодовиків. Чому?
Ми з вами розберемося впродовж уроку.
Ще нам важливо і потрібно знати те,
що у льодовиках міститься
велика кількість прісної води.
Це такі запаси прісної води на планеті,
які законсервовані в
твердому стані в льодовиках.
Знову ж таки, підкреслюємо, це
рухоме природне тіло, тобто, лід рухомий.
І швидкість його в середньому
становить 1-2 м на рік.
Звідки він і куди рухається
ми також сьогодні розберемо.
Якщо подивитися за місцем
утворення, де утворилися льодовики,
то виділяють два таких види: гірські
льодовики і покривне зледеніння.
Ми почнемо з вами з гірських льодовиків.
Зрозуміло з назви, що
вони утворюються в горах,
але чи однаково вони виглядають на
карті: і гірське, і покривне зледеніння?
Перед вами є декілька зображень.
Нижнє зображення - це вигляд
льодовиків з програмки Google Планета,
ви можете її також
відкрити, якщо є можливість,
і подивитися як виглядають, наблизити
ці льодовики і уважненько роздивитися.
От ми бачимо гірські
вершини, вкриті льодовиками.
А ось ми бачимо покривне зледеніння,
яке в даному випадку острів
Гренландія і навколишні острови.
Якщо ж ми подивимося на фрагменти карт,
то ми бачимо - ось позначені такими білими
плямами у нас вершини вкриті льодовиками,
і знову ж таки бачимо Гренландія
на карті, як теж показано,
як вкрита льодовиком.
І поруч є декілька, також
ще бачимо, островів,
які також, видно, вкриті льодовиками.
Переходимо до гірських льодовиків
і розбираємося детальніше:
де, як вони утворюються, де утворилися
і де найбільші гірські льодовики у нас є?
Найбільші гірські льодовики
у нас є в горах Аляски,
зокрема найбільший - це льодовик Беринга.
Пам'ятаєте, ми з вами вчили
на початку року дослідників,
і був серед них Вітус Беринг,
от саме на його честь названий
гірський льодовик в межах Аляски.
Також у нас є гірські льодовики в
найвищих гірських системах світу
це Гімалаї, Памір, Тянь-Шань.
Форма гірського льодовика
залежить від рельєфу гір.
Під своєю величезною
масою та силою тяжіння
льодовик поступо
спускається по долинах вниз.
От ми бачимо так, як спускається.
Давайте ж розберемося, де саме
утворюються гірські льодовики.
Гірські льодовики
утворюються вище певної лінії.
Це називається снігова лінія — рівень,
вище якого снігу випадає більше,
ніж встигає розтанути за теплий період.
Що це значить? Це значить, що там мають
бути мінусові температури протягом року.
Чи в усіх горах ця лінія
знаходиться на однаковій висоті?
Давайте поглянемо на приклади і
розберемося з висотою снігової лінії.
От у нас на першому
зображенні вулкан Кіліманджаро.
Він знаходиться майже біля екватора.
Ось бачимо екватор,
ось вулкан Кіліманджаро.
Його висота 5895 м, а
висота снігової лінії на 5000 м.
Тобто, лінія, вища якої протягом
року зберігаються від'ємні температури,
знаходиться на висоті 5000 м.
Далі йдемо.
Гора Джомолунгма — найвища
вершина світу, висота 8848 м,
а розташована вона уже трошки північніше,
знаходиться на 27
градусі північної широти.
І дивимося, хоча гора вища, однак снігова
лінія вже опускається трошки нижче,
і висота снігової лінії у нас
4500 м. Чому ж так буває?
Тому що, ми пам'ятаємо з теми "Атмосфера",
що з висотою температура знижується.
Тому чим вище, тим холодніше.
Однак залежить також і від
широти, де знаходиться гора,
тому що, знову ж таки, з
тієї самої теми ми пам'ятаємо,
що кількість сонячної енергії
збільшується від полюсу до екватора,
і температури, також, протягом
року вищі ближче до екватора.
Тепер поглянемо на інший приклад
— гора Монблан висота 4808 м.
Але подивіться, на скільки
північніше вона вже розташована,
це вже 45 градус північної широти.
Не дивлячись на те, що гора висока,
висота снігової лінії
спускається до 2500 м.
Наступним нашим прикладом
будуть Скандинавські гори.
Ми бачимо, тут навіть
проходить Північне полярне коло,
тобто, це набагато ближче
до полюсу, ніж до екватора,
таким чином, снігова лінія
спускається ще нижче, вже до 1500 м.
Тобто, ми можемо зробити висновок,
що висота снігової лінії
залежить від широти місцевості,
на якій знаходиться
гора, та від висоти гори.
І, власне, тепер ми можемо відповісти,
чому ж в Австраліїї
немає гірських льодовиків.
Давайте повернемося до нашої Австралії.
Ось у нас іде Великий Вододільний хребет,
ми пам'ятаємо з теми
літосфера, що це старі гори,
а відповідно вони не такі високі.
А Австралія знаходиться в жарких широтах.
Тому беремо високу температуру
та невисокі гори — маємо відповідь,
чому ж там немає гірських льодовиків.
Тому що для того, щоб постійно
протягом року були мінусові температури,
цим горам не вистачає висоти.
От ми з вами й зрозуміли, чому на одному з
материків Землі немає гірських льодовиків.
Тепер переходимо до покривного зледеніння.
Оскільки ми з вами з'ясували, що снігова
лінія зменшується з просуванням на північ,
то в полярних широтах ми
маємо покривне зледеніння,
і дане зледеніння не залежить від рельєфу,
а вкриває рівнинні простори
суцільним льодовим щитом.
Найбільше покривне
зледеніння в Антарктиді.
Ось бачимо, майже вся територія
Антарктиди вкрита льодовиком.
Потужність цього льодовикового
щита в середньому 1720 м.
Давайте подивимось в атласі,
або, можливо, пригадаєте,
якщо хтось знає, яка висота
найвищої вершини Кримських гір.
Роман-Кош — 1545 м.
А тут середня потужність
льодовикового щита 1720 м.
Тобто більше ніж Роман-Кош.
А якщо ми візьмемо максимальну
потужність льодовикового покриву,
то вона становить 4776 м.
Пригадайте гору Монблан,
яку ми сьогодні вже згадували,
її висота 4807 м, тобто їх
можна порівнювати за висотою.
Уявляєте, який це потужний крижаний щит!
Але від покривних льодовиків час
від часу відколюються великі частини,
які ми називаємо айсберги.
Бачимо, ось у нас приклад айсберга,
над поверхнею води є лише верхівка,
а більша частина схована під водою.
І нещодавно, в 2019 році
відколовся найбільший айсберг
від антарктично-шельфового
льодовика Еймері
і його маса, подивіться,
будь-ласка, це навіть важко уявити,
315 млрд тон, це величезна глиба, яка
тепер рухається водами Південного океану.
Яку ж роботу виконують
льодовики? Давайте з'ясуємо.
Льодовики невтомні трудівники.
Вони виконують декілька видів робіт.
Вони руйнують гірські
породи, транспортують їх
і створюють нові форми рельєфу.
Тобто, рухаючись по долині, гірський
льодовик захоплює всі частинки,
каміння, пісок, гравій, все,
що можна підхопити і понести,
він захоплює ці частинки,
вони вмерзають в його товщу,
і переносить льодовик їх далі долиною.
Таким чином утворюються ось
такі коритоподібні форми долин.
Льодовик розширює долини,
згладжує нерівності, шліфує каміння,
таким чином утворюючи нові
форми рельєфу і розширюючи існуючі.
Коли він переносить їх далі,
і коли льодовик спускається нижче
снігової лінії, він починає танути.
І розтанувши нижче снігової лінії
частину цих відкладів він залишає там,
а частину вода несе далі по долині.
Всі льодовикові відклади
називаються морена,
запам'ятайте цей термін,
будь-ласка, це важливо.
Із відкладів льодовика
утворюються нові форми рельєфу.
Таким чином, льодовик створює нові
форми рельєфу і руйнує уже існуюючі.
Тепер розглянемо ще одне важливе
питання, яке стосується льодовиків.
Це значення льодовиків.
Ми їх більшість сьогодні назвали,
тому давайте узагальнемо.
Льодовики впливають
на клімат всієї планети.
Пам'ятаєте з теми
"Атмосфера" поняття альбедо?
Тобто, відбиваюча
здатність земної поверхні?
Ви вчили, що від льодовика,
снігу відбивається найбільша
кількість сонячних променів.
Річки живляться також талими льодовиковими
водами і ми вже з вами розглядали,
наприклад, такі великі річки
як Хуанхе, Янцзи, Меконг
беруть початок саме в гірських льодовиках
і живляться талими льодовиковими водами.
Щойно ми сказали, що льодовики
утворюють форми рельєфу
і також ми сьогодні згадували,
що в льодовиках зосереджено
третина всієї прісної води на планеті.
З льодовиками ми розібралися, тепер
переходимо до багаторічної мерзлоти.
Що ж це таке і чому ми вивчаємо її окремо?
Це не льодовик? Ні, це
постійно мерзлий шар землі.
Бачимо, ось у нас промерзлий шар землі,
де температура протягом року
залишється нижче нуля градусів.
І такі мерзлі шари грунту можуть
бути від кількох років до тисячоліть.
Яка потужність багаторічної мерзлоти?
Ви бачите, що потужність з
цього промерзлого шару грунту
може становити від кількох
метрів до декількох кілометрів,
наприклад, як на території Сибіру.
В багаторічній мерзлоті також
зустрічаються товщі промерзлого грунту
із колишніх давніх льодовикових періодів,
такий шар грунту
називають викопним льодом.
Якщо поглянути на карту
поширення багаторічної мерзлоти,
то ось ми бачимо території, де
поширена багаторічна мерзлота,
і бачимо за насиченням кольору,
який відсоток площі займає
ця багаторічна мерзлота.
Від території, де майже 90%
- це багаторічна мерзлота,
далі менша, і тут блакитний
колір це окремі ділянки,
які мають промерзлий грунт.
Що ж характерно для
багаторічної мерзлоти?
Це як такий вічний холод, який дуже
довго вважався нерухомим та стабільним,
але його такий спокій, така
стабільність є дуже підступною,
тому що, коли вічна мерзлота в теплий
період року починає поступово танути,
тане верхній шар грунту,
до декількох метрів,
і ми можемо бачити ось такий ланшафт.
А тане нерівномірно, тому
утворюються так звані мерзлотні горби.
Танення вічної мерзлоти підступне,
оскільки верхній шар грунту
стає просочений водою,
а знизу лід і він, як на катку, з'їжджає,
навіть може призводити до
розривів рослинного покриву.
В таких умовах досить складно, наприклад,
будувати будинок або прокладати дорогу.
І коли прокладалися в Сибіру перші дороги,
будівельники були дуже здивовані,
адже нещодавно прокладені нові дороги
невідомим чином виявлялися розламані,
якась ділянка провалилася, якась навпаки
була піднята на висоту декількох метрів
і незрозуміло, яка сила
поруйнувала щойно прокладені дороги.
Виявляється, все ж таки,
це витівки вічної мерзлоти.
Вічна мерзлота іноді приносить сюрпризи.
Зокрема, в 1977 році під
двохметровим шаром мерзлих порід
було знайдено майже
повністю збереженого мамонта,
який, вчені з'ясували,
мав вік 40 тисяч років,
і знайшли його біля витоків річки Колима.
А іншого мамонта, якого
ми бачимо на слайді,
було знайдено уже у 21
столітті на півострові Ямал.
І вченим це була справжня знахідка,
оскільки вони могли з'ясувати,
наприклад, що їв мамонт в той час,
оскільки він дуже швидко потрапив в болото
і болото не дало можливості
доступу повітря, сонячним променям
і він зберігся повністю, вмерзнувши
потім в багаторічну мерзлоту,
то вчені змогли не просто
роздивитися мамонта,
а і отримати багато
корисної інформації з того,
що разом з ним до нас потрапило.
На цьому ми закінчуємо з вами вивчення
льодовиків та багаторічної мерзлоти.
Вдома, будь-ласка, почитайте
параграфи, які відповідають даній темі.
На слайді ви бачите
підручники різних авторів
і номер параграфу з відповідною темою.
Також наступного разу ми будемо
з вами вивчати тему “Підземні води”
і навіть спробуємо провести
невеличкий експеримент.
До побачення!